the show has started to get some
attention and
we've had
journalists come out here to the
property
the family was
super nervous
they're living in this small town
and one of the biggest networks in the
country comes from kiev to do a story on
them
and the first journalists were they were
from one plus one
[Music]
the uh the kukuruza mafia shut us down
but then that week
went by many more journalists coming and
by the end there are professionals i
mean whoa
was just chill and actually it got to a
point where it was too much and they're
like yeah we don't really want any more
journalists coming i could feel it from
that was cool
unexpected
[Music]
so
it was on the first note the second day
the guy came over with that little metal
thing
to find out where to dig the well
and
the well digging has been this ongoing
process
for the my
almost my full six weeks
[Laughter]
yes
today got up very early like five
o'clock because i've been wanting to do
this ride to mariopo
okay
um for those that don't know the region
far in the east
pretty close to the russian border and
what is it in in total it's like
i think it turned out to like
160 kilometers or something like that
so maybe 80 miles
[Music]
i was inspired it was just like
the sun was coming right up over the
horizon and i was
feeling great
something came through me i just it felt
amazing i mean there was a very strong
headwind which
makes it slower and harder when you're
on a bike but i was just on a different
plane
in a different realm
so
[Music]
got to marry opal
loaded up on some food and then that
wind hit my back
and
started flying started really moving
[Music]
so eventually got back
to osapenco and was very tired
but again no matter what my mood is or
how i feel that little girl elisa comes
up to me and changes everything and she
came up and gave me a sweet little hug
that little girl is so powerful
it was very hot it was
i don't know 36
celsius what is that up around 100
degrees something like that the only
option was to go to this lake this
reservoir that's 5k away the grasses
blew
softly in the wind
the sounds of splashing again just the
simplicity here and
it's hard to explain but i feel
in ukraine there's a depth
there's a realness there's um
there's a wealth here not i mean not
monetarily you don't see it
that's the message that gets sent to the
world obviously
war
bad politics bad economy this is what
gets exported
what's special here is
the people
i found there to be some very deep souls
here and some amazing
[Music]
people like this family
they've taken me in like one of their
own
[Music]
i think they'll be in my life
until the end of my life
no they're not a traditional family
i could go to six different families and
get six different stories
and that's how it goes right but this
family no matter what they eat or what
they pray to poor
wow
so much to be learned
so much beauty in them so much love in
them
[Music]
those ukrainians that go abroad they go
to the states or europe or wherever and
they get better job opportunities and
they
they move up materially
i would think and i don't know and i
can't speak for anyone but i would think
there there would be something missing
there would be like
something deep within them
that can't be filled
it can't be found in america it can't be
found in europe
[Music]
that's here
and who knows i'm i'm i'm an outsider i
don't know but i think when i go back to
the states
i will miss that and i'm not even from
here
but this ukrainian countryside is is
tough it's it's no joke i'm not
let's say it's a simple life by any
stretch
it's a difficult life
but in another sense it's simple
and like
you just need each other
in a lake and a hot day
and that's it
and that can be some of the best
moments
in life
larry had this old
bike like this ancient bike from soviet
times story
story started
but i wanted to go out and
explore the town and then
go up to this field
uh that's far away
i got on this old creaky bike
gone
and uh
well it's almost like the the harder you
pedal
it doesn't really go any faster i just
it wants to do its own thing which is go
one
one speed and one speed only
my quick road bike
very much is like america
there's efficiency there's a goal ahead
there's something to work towards in the
future and it gets there quickly but by
doing so it quite often misses the
moment it's actually in
and in ukraine
well
that ukrainian bike i was on was slow
and it didn't work with efficiency
and much like ukraine the the future is
unknown you can't plan too far ahead
but by
being in that existence
it forces the rider to observe the
surroundings to be in
that specific moment
i'm not going to say what's better or
worse
but it was very cool
in this countryside experience to get in
to the moment much more than i can in
america
i think that's that's what the
the place does too it's just you you you
put the bike in the mix you put the
war is not that far away in the mix you
put this
in the mix you put the sunflowers field
in there and then this completely
different culture and everything feels
very surreal
and there's a beauty in that
i mean there's no beauty in the war but
there's a beauty in
the difference
i put my bike down up at the field
relaxed and
just chilled out for a while daydreamed
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
the bike has always been
my refuge even as a kid
[Music]
it was always that place to go to to
in a way meditate and
escape
and it's always felt comfortable for me
[Music]
so in this experience
living in osupenko the bike has been
a savior for me because it's sort of
reset those batteries
[Music]
um
i caught a fly yesterday
killed it
and ate it
just because
[Music]
it's not like the family does that they
don't do that
i just naturally uh ate a fly for no
reason
so it's probably uh
a good idea if i get back into an urban
environment
this is terrible
[Music]
i've been here a long time
but it's
it's my time to leave now
i feel it i feel
i feel in the weather today it got
cloudy and
a thunderstorm happened off in the
distance
i feel it in the the blackberry trees
the
they were juicy and sweet when i got
here now they've they've gotten dry and
hard
[Music]
me
it started as
[Music]
a fish out of water
removed from water
and that's how i felt when i first got
here
and now
[Music]
you lose fish
with this family
now i'm in the water
[Music]
you